[Musique]
et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
aurélien pradié bonjour je merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous vous avez été
élu dimanche député du lot et
félicitations merci d'exeter général des
républicains on est ensemble pendant 20
minutes ou un interview en partenariat
avec la presse régionale représenté par
julien lécuyer de la voix du nord pour
julien bonjour yanbu jomby super bon je
me aurélien pradié vous avez évidemment
coûte emmanuel macron hier soir trois
jours à pas après la perte de sa
majorité absolue s'est adressé aux
français à 20h pendant 8 minutes est ce
que pour vous il a entendu il a compris
le message des urnes
je n'ai pas bien compris ce qu'il aurait
compris
quelle est la situation aujourd'hui un
pays qui s'annonce difficile à gouverner
un emmanuel macron qui considère que
rien et athènes en sa légitimité
politique alors que les français lui ont
adressé un message très clair en disant
que c'était ses choix politiques qui le
contester profondément dans cette
élection législative et la légitimité
politique est attendue évidemment
lorsque vous êtes président de la
république dans un quinquennat ou une
élection présidentielle est suivie
immédiatement d'une élection législative
vous tirez votre légitimité
institutionnelle de l'élection
présidentielle mais votre légitimité
politique foule attirée du parlement de
l'assemblée nationale il ne l'a pas
aujourd'hui il aurait dû remettre en
cause son projet hier soir est très
clairement et on n'a pas senti
d'inflexion majeure sur son projet
présidentiel et à fixer un cadre de
prêts très clair celui de son projet
sortie des urnes est ce que vous pensez
qu'il aurait dû tout de suite donné des
gages évidemment parce que il n'a pas
compris que les françaises et les
français l'avaient été élu pour des
raisons diverses et variées notamment
parce que il s'était retrouvé face à
marine le pen qu'il avait totalement
organiser cela politiquement d'ailleurs
certain cynisme depuis plusieurs mois
mais qu'il ne l'avait pas élu sur son
projet politique c'est ça le la forme
d'imposture la forme d'incompréhension
qu'il y a et ce qui m'a le plus frappé
en réalité c'est que il persiste dans
une démarche politique qui à mon sens
nous a conduit à cette assemblée
ingouvernable cette démarche politique
c'est le dépassement au lac entendu hier
à nouveau dire j'ai bien compris que les
françaises et les français voulaient
encore plus de dépassements politique
pour vous ce n'est pas vrai et c'est
même l'exact inverse et c'est là que
pardon de vous le dire aussi brutalement
mais il ne comprend rien parce que
déconnecté sûrement des réalités parce
que ne s'entendent pas le pays ce que
les français lui ont dit dimanche
dernier c'est qu'il voulait à nouveau
qu'il y ait des convictions politiques
dans notre pays il ne voulait pas de
cette espèce d'agglomérât
incompréhensible qui fait que lorsqu'on
rentre en macro ni on abandonne dès ce
qui rentre en tous les cas abandonnent
leurs convictions le dépassement
politique je dis à nos auditeurs qui
peut être doivent se dire c'est quand
même bien le déplacement politique ça
évite et chamailleries politiques mais
quand vous éviter le débat politique sur
le fond quand vous tenter d'effacer les
conditions vous en venez à n'avoir au
final que les extrêmes qui incarne
quelque chose et cela c'est la
responsabilité politique majeur des
manuels macron en voulant organiser le
dépassement politique qui a été
séduisant pour une partie des françaises
et des français il y a quelques années
il a organisé le désordre politique
notre démocratie a besoin de repères
sont des clivages droite gauche très
claires au sein de l'assemblée nationale
j'appelle au retour des clivages
politiques je l' ai toujours dit
d'ailleurs et vous savez quand je disais
cela il ya cinq ans je prêcher dans le
désert les français avaient élu un jeune
président de la république considérait
que c'était formidable il y aurait plus
de débat politique confond tout le monde
se mettrait d'accord en claquant des
doigts non c'est pas ça la politique la
politique c'est pas la chamaillerie mais
la politique c'est avoir des convictions
différentes d'ailleurs parfois pour
réussir à aller vers un objectif commun
les grande coalition allemande dont on
nous parle beaucoup aujourd'hui c'est
quoi la grande coalition allemande s'est
pas l'effacement des clivages c'est
simplement sur certains sujets être
capable de se mettre d'accord c'est ce
que nous avons réclamé depuis cinq ans
par mois je suis député depuis j'ai été
député les cinq années passées
combien de fois avons-nous fait des 10 n
des centaines des milliers de
propositions au gouvernement qu'il les a
toujours refusé et donc je le dis à
emmanuel macron si vous n'avez pas
compris monsieur le président de la
république que le dépassement des
clivages c'était la mort lente et
confortable de notre démocratie alors
vous n'avez rien compris à ce qui se
passe dans le pays on met sur la manière
dont on peut gouverner maintenant lui
dit nous devons apprendre à gouverner et
légiférer
différemment il dit la responsabilité la
majorité c'est de s'élargir soit en
bâtissant un contrat de coalition sont
en construisant des majorités texte par
tex le contrat de coalition vous l'avez
refusé est-ce que du coup vous êtes
prêts à construire des majorités texte
par texte avec lui et comment peut-être
expliquons-nous sur le contrat de
coalition d'abord je je déteste un peu
cette époque où on en voit des phrases
des mots qui paraissent très beau
coalition compromis et c'est bon
concrètement c'est quoi le contrat de
coalition c'est l'idée que l'on gouverne
avec emmanuel macron je le refuse pas
par sectarisme pas par réflexe primaire
je le refuse parce que son projet
politique n'est pas le mien c'est quand
même fou droit le plus strict de ne pas
épouser le projet politique d' emmanuel
macron il y à bien des sujets sur
lesquels nous n'avons pas la même vision
de la société et donc je refuse de
gouverner avec quelqu'un qui n'a pas la
même vision de la société comment il
devrait d'ailleurs refusé de le faire
avec quelqu'un qui n'a pas la même
vision commune donc ce contrat de
coalition nous l'avons refusée parce que
non seulement c'est un non sens au
regard de nos idées et de nos valeurs
mais en plus je le redis c'est ce qui
nous amènera encore un peu plus vers la
bim
lorsque jacques chirac et excusez moi
mais ce problème est en fait ce que ce
que vous nous dites c'est que ce qui est
en vigueur dont beaucoup de démocraties
européennes et qui finalement fonctionne
c'est à dire des contrats qui permettent
au sein d'un même d'un gouvernement
d'allier des partis qui garde pourtant
l'aurait leur identité n'est absolument
pas possible en france non mais vous
vous trompez sur la comparaison elle est
un peu expéditive
d'abord les un peu de temps les vous
avez raison mais les pays dont vous
parlez n'ont pas les mêmes régimes
électoraux que nous les députés ne sont
pas élus de la même manière les députés
n'ont pas les mêmes missions les
collectivités locales dans ces pays là
ont des responsabilités y compris
législatives que nous n'avons pas dans
notre propre pays
arrêtons avec ces comparaisons là notre
république notre vème république notre
démocratie n'est pas la démocratie
suisse et pour tout vous dire j'ai pas
très envie qu'elle le devienne nous
avons un tempérament france est une
démocratie française qui doit s'assumer
comme tel je vous disais tout à l'heure
que lorsque jacques chirac est élu au
deuxième tour de l'élection
présidentielle face à marine le pen se
pose à l'époque pour lui la question de
faire un gouvernement de coalition il le
refuse à l'époque on le critique et
jacques chirac dit la chose suivante qui
désormais une vérité il dit si je le
fais dans quelques années il n'y aura
plus que les extrêmes pour faire la
différence il avait raison est ce que
nous vivons aujourd'hui c'est exactement
cela et donc il y à une nécessité un peu
difficile pour la droite républicaine à
résister à l'air du temps qui
consisterait à nous pousser dans les
bras ou des extrêmes ou déraisonnable
que serait la montée des extrêmes c'est
uniquement emmanuel macron c'est pas
aussi l'affaiblissement des partis
traditionnels et notamment de la droite
qui aujourd'hui n'ont pas apporté les
candidats et les réponses à ses
électeurs il ya trois choses on a passé
un peu sous silence ce que vous m'avez
souvent entendu dénoncer qui était la
pratique du débauchage politique à
chaque fois qu emmanuel macron est allé
faire une prise de guerre est allé
débaucher
quelqu'un qui a trahi sa famille
politique à chaque fois on a considéré
que c'était formidable
ça distrayait notre vie politique et je
pense que ça va faire mal extraordinaire
à la vie publique mais souvent entendu
dire que au delà de la traîtrise
individuel que je déteste il y avait
aussi le fait que ceux qui trahissent et
leur famille politique pour un gyrophare
sur la voiture faisait du mal à la
démocratie nous y sommes aujourd'hui est
par ailleurs j'ajoute que sûrement vous
avez raison de dire que dans cet espace
là ce qui nous a affaiblis c'est d'abord
les attaques permanentes des manières
macron qui n'a eu de cesse n'ont pas de
porter un projet politique mais
d'affaiblir les autres pour faire le
ménage et je suis d'accord avec vous
quitte à perturber ce qui va nous
écouter pour dire que derrière le vote
est reine et nuls sont il n'y a pas que
du désespoir il ya aussi un espoir
l'espoir de vraies convictions
politiques que d'autres n'incarne plus
et l'espoir de retourner la table parce
que oui sur bien des sujets il va
falloir retourner la table je n'ai pas
les mêmes remèdes que la france
insoumise où le rassemblement national
mais je sais que sur l'écologie sur le
travail sur les salaires sur la pauvreté
sur le handicap nous avons besoin de
retourner la table reste monsieur
prédire que donc vous refusez la
coalition l'a bien saisi qu'en est-il de
négociation texte par texte pour avancer
c'est ce que nous faisons depuis cinq
ans et qui aujourd'hui la refuser depuis
cinq ans mais pas nous c'est emmanuel
macron je vous prends deux exemples très
concrets
j'ai bataillé à l'assemblée nationale
pour porter une loi contre les violences
conjugales j'ai souhaité à l'époque que
dans cette loi soit intégré une mesure
pour créer une juridiction spécialisée
pour protéger mieux les femmes et les
enfants victimes de violence ça a été
refusé par le gouvernement aujourd'hui à
l'assemblée nationale nous avons une
majorité pour le faire mais nous allons
proposer j'ai été un de ceux qui a porté
la proposition de des conjugale isation
de l'allocation adulte handicapé à
l'époque qu'il a refusé le président de
la république et son gouvernement
aujourd'hui nous avons une majorité
parlementaire pour le faire et nous
allons faire des propositions sur la
question du prix des carburants nous
bataillons pour détaxer massivement les
carburants est arrivé à 1 euro 50
maximum qu'il a refusé depuis plusieurs
mois emmanuel macron nous allons le
proposer c'est sur cela que les choses
se fonction comprend bien vous dit
contrairement à ce qu'a laissé entendre
emmanuel macron hier la balle n'est pas
dans notre camp elle est dans le camp du
président de la république et laissez
vous faire porter une responsabilité
pour vous oui enfin la ficelle est un
peu grosse quand il dit il va nous
falloir inventer une nouvelle manière de
boumerdés non non excusez moi monsieur
présents dans le public mais il va vous
falloir inventer une nouvelle manière de
gouverner et cette manière nous la
connaissons toutes les propositions que
j'évoquais à l'instant nous allons les
poser sur la table dès la semaine
prochaine dès la semaine prochaine les
françaises et les français auront le
détail de ce que les républicains nous
proposons pour faire avancer le pays de
quelle manière nous allons formellement
travailler avec notre nouveau président
du groupe olivier marc l'ex à la d
initions d'une série de propositions en
disant si vous voulez avancer sur ces
sujets évidemment que nous sommes là
pour avancer mais jamais ne nous
demander de nous compromettre dans un
gouvernement commun juste un mot parce
qu'il ya quand même un texte fondateur
c'est le budget c'est généralement là
qu'on voit qui est dans l'opposition qui
est dans la majorité est ce que selon ce
que contient ce budget vous pourriez le
voter oui votre phrase est correcte
selon ce que contient ce budget mais je
ne sais pas ce que contient ce dj c'est
ce que dit olivier marc l'ex nouveau
président du groupe heller qui dit pas
de chèque en blanc et qui finalement
renvoie aussi la balle des
responsabilités à emmanuel macron en
disant mais avant tout donné nous un
projet très clair et bien sûr parce que
pour l'instant pardon mais on enfile des
perles en se disant ce qu'on est capable
de se mettre d'accord et ce qu'on est
favorable à l'intérêt général est ce que
ben oui oui oui d'accord mais
concrètement des quoi je le redis sur
l'allocation adulte handicapé ce
président de la république vous êtes
prêt dans les trois semaines qui
viennent à des conjugalité l'allocation
adulte handicapé sur les violences
conjugales vous êtes prêt monsieur le
président la république dans les trois
semaines a créé la juridiction
spécialisée vous êtes prêt à faire
revenir les vacances en fait rien n'est
pas une liste pas une liste de courses
une liste de mesures qui peuvent changer
la vie des français moi je ne suis pas
députés pour faire les courses ou pour
faire de la politique politicienne je
suis député pour changer la vie de mes
concitoyens quand le président de
république dise dit que c'est majorité
doivent se concerter avec smart s est ce
que ces majorités elles peuvent se
construire selon vous avec le
rassemblement national c'est une vraie
question que je me pose personnellement
je m'inquiète de la banalisation de ce
que je considère comme des extrêmes
je considère que le rassemblement
national est un parti extrême je ne
parle pas des électeurs c'est tout à
fait autre chose et d'ailleurs je lis
très librement que les électeurs qui
votent et rennes ne sont pas qu'en
colère ils attendent aussi quelque chose
est aussi un espoir qu'il nous faut
entendre nous la droite républicaine
pour nour bâtir je considère que la
france insoumise est un parti extrémiste
et je considère que l'homme comme
l'autre ont des difficultés réelles avec
les valeurs républicaines et notamment
la france est soumise mais ça vaut pour
le rassemblement national et donc l'idée
de main de mais les mets voix à celle de
partis d'extrêmes me pose une vraie
question ce que je voudrais c'est que la
droite républicaine soit suffisamment
forte pour ne pas avoir à se poser ces
questions-là mais pourtant vous allez
devoir vous la posez cette question je
pense évidemment à l'élection du
président de la commission d'aidé des
finances qui revient normalement au
premier groupe d'opposition ça c'est
plutôt quelque chose de traditionnel
c'est un vote qui va être qui va qui va
donner lieu à l'élection soit a priori
d'un représentant de l'art du relation
d'amour nationale ou de la france 1-1
soumises quelle sera votre position à
moi vous ne ferez jamais mettre un
bulletin dans l'urne qui soit pour la
france un soumises ou pour le
rassemblement national excusez moi même
je suis un garçon assez basique et je
considère qu' aucun des deux n'a partie
à mes valeurs politiques non mais qui
doit présider la commission des finances
pour vous en l'espèce la ceni décision
une décision de la majorité de la rare
chez lui hier dans le parisien qu'il a
dit c'est le rassemblement national il a
raison dans une logique institutionnelle
bon une fois qu'on a passé la logique
ainsi chayan moment où chaque député
prend un bulletin mais non de suez et le
glisse dans l'eau mais vous le savez
avoir un barrage juste pardon avec la
majorité présidentielle et les
républicains pour que ce soit un membre
des républicains le président de la
commission des finances et non un manque
d les filles du rassemblement national
c'est une question que l'on s'est posée
en réunion de groupe la semaine dernière
que nous allons nous reposer la semaine
prochaine peut-être qu'il faut que ceux
qui nous écoutent et nous regardent
comprennent ce qu'est la présidence de
la commission des finances lorsque vous
présidez la commission des finances vous
le faites en toute indépendance
à l'égard de qui que ce soit et donc ce
n'est pas parce que vous êtes élu par
les voix des uns et des autres que vous
devenez les serviteurs des uns des
autres le président aulas futur
président de la commission des finances
a une liberté totale pour faire des
investigations y compris contre le
gouvernement et donc c'est sur ce sujet
là qu'il faut que l'on verrait ce que
c'est un levier démocratique
suffisamment puissant pour aller y
compris titille le gouvernement ou lui
demander des comptes sur des sujets sur
lesquels ne veut pas rendre des comptes
et auquel cas pourquoi pas de l'assuré
nous mêmes mais tout ça est dans la
balle tout ses sept balles l'aller dans
le cadre de la majorité c'est que
emmanuel macron que l'ablation se
débrouiller avec leur
majorité n'est pas censée prendre part
au vote c'est plutôt un c'est un usage
s'est pas c'est pas dans le règlement de
l'intérieur de l'assemblée nationale
donc vous leur demandez à la 7 me vous
députés de cette majorité de prendre
parti dans cette fois ci il faut qu'ils
prennent leurs responsabilités enfin
c'est un peu facile d'avoir créé le
chaos à tous égards et les députés de la
république un marché qui ont contribué
depuis cinq ans parce que le spectacle
qu'ils ont donné à l'assemblée nationale
de blocage permanent les propositions
des oppositions et et d'amateurisme a
contribué pendant des mois mais la
responsabilité revient aussi au groupe
ait l air de prendre votre et donc tu es
nous le ferons moi je vous parle de moi
persuy personnellement je le fais le
groupe fait ce sera liberté de vote
oui comme à chaque fois d'ailleurs nous
sommes des grands garçons et les grandes
filles et encore plus depuis qu'on a été
ré chacun pendant la séance bien sûr
chacun prendra ses responsabilités
un dernier mot là dessus avant de parler
de votre parti évidemment s qu'elisabeth
gants pour vous doit demander un vote de
confiance de l'assemblée nationale le
courage politique pousserez à le faire
est-ce qu'elle aura ce courage politique
je n'en suis pas certain du tout mais
c'est une situation qui de toute façon
ne pourra pas durer ainsi je ne crois
pas la dissolution tout ça c'est pour se
distraire les uns les autres mais il n'y
aura pas de dissolution ce qui me craint
le plus ce qui m'inquiète le plus fort
mais moi c'est c'est l'idée que emmanuel
macron s'accommode du chaos parce que
lorsque vous voulez incarner la
stabilité face aux extrêmes le chaos
ça vous va et d'ailleurs depuis cinq ans
il l'a plutôt bien organisé
face à l'extrême droite face à l'extrême
gauche et je ne voudrais pas que dans
une idée cynique dont je n'espère pas
que le président la république les je le
dis très franchement il y ait cette
volonté pendant cinq ans d'organiser le
chaos pour apparaître comme étant le
point de stabilité ce serait une faute
politique républicaine et démocratique
colossal exclusion à messi dernière
question sur elisabeth bande mais si
elle n'y a pas de votre confiant de vote
de confiance qui est demandé est ce que
vous pourrez reconsidérer la question de
la motion de censure
oui mais nous n'avons pas aujourd'hui
une majorité a d'un seul pour porter une
chambre sans câble à vous de voter avec
d'autres partis pour la motion de
sentiments la motion de censure c'est
non seulement bloqué le gouvernement
mais c'est aussi proposer soit même un
projet politique un pardon je suis un
garçon basique est ce que vous me vous
envie est ce que j'envisage de partager
un projet politique avec la france et
insoumise avec le rassemblement national
ma réponse est non on va parler ce qui
s'est passé dans votre groupe mais oui
olivier marc l'ex donc est le vôtre
nouveau président de groupe est ce que
ce serait pas quand même la victoire la
ned précise de la ligne wauquiez ciotti
je n'en sais rien c'est d'abord la
victoire d'olivier marne ex que je
félicite qui
vote est secret vous le savez tous les
cas aujourd'hui c'est notre président de
groupe et c'est la prison de tout le
monde et je sais qu'il assumera
parfaitement à cette responsabilité il
en a l'expérience la droiture et la
solidité mais ne fait pas des
projections et des billards a dit bande
sur l'élection interne ou non je suis
moi aussi je suis plutôt basique c'est
très bien vous avez raison c'est
d'ailleurs comme ça qu'on comprend mieux
la démocratie et la vie politique et en
l'espèce olivier marleix
c'est la victoire de celui qui sera
notre représentant du rang durant les
années qui viennent et dont on sait
qu'il n'y aura aucune discussion
possible sur des marchandages
politiciens avec les uns et les autres
concernant le parti puisque christian
jacob à dire il quittera la tête du
parti dans les prochains jours est ce
que vous avez envie lui succéder c'est
pas tout à fait comme ça que ça se passe
un peu plus compliqué bien sûr une
affaire de succession si votre question
est de dire vous êtes candidat elles
sont claires je ne sais pas quelles
seront les conditions électorales je ne
sais pas tout ça et je vous dis très
sincèrement si j'étais candidat
aujourd'hui si j'avais pris ma décision
je vous le dirai ce que je sais en
revanche c'est que si notre famille
politique ne secoue pas et je le dis
sans injonction je le dis parce que
j'aime cette famille politique et les
valeurs qu'elle porte elle va mourir et
si elle meurt ce sera un problème pour
nous certainement on en sera fortement
triste mais ce sera un vrai problème
pour notre démocratie nous avons besoin
regard de tout ce que je vous ai dit
tout à l'heure de ses points de repères
là et donc nous sommes à la croisée des
chemins on voit bien dans la vie
politique que des cycles sont en train
de passer et christian jacob a fait un
travail incroyable de dévouement de
fidélité à nos valeurs désormais on
arrive sur un autre cycle et pour ma
part j'ai suffisamment exploré les
aventures individuelles depuis quelques
années c'est plutôt mon tempérament bon
caractère vous êtes élu dans une terre
aussi hostile que le lot vous forger un
caractère assez solitaire et individuel
mais j'ai suffisamment explorées ça ces
expériences là pour avoir désormais
envie d'une expérience plus collective
et je crois vous avez plutôt envie d'y
aller mais quelles seront les conditions
tous les cas je j'ai dit un peu
brutalement le dimanche soir de
l'élection que y compris ma génération
nous ne revenions pas l'assemblée
nationale pour un fil des perles oui
parce que si on revient et qu'on
s'endort tout doucement on va on ne se
réveillera pas il faut que chacun aime
être le déclic parce que là vous nous
dites vous avez envie réfléchissez mais
votre décision des papilles ce qu'est ce
qui va faire que votre décision sera
prise le collectif est ce que les amis
politiques est ce que moi même nous
sommes capables de lucidité de faire des
efforts ça vaut pour mes amis politiques
comme pour moi en se disant c'est le
moment d'incarner quelque chose qui
attire l'attention des français sur non
ça vaut sur la forme mais pas seulement
ça vaut aussi sur le principalement sur
le fond
qu'avons nous à dire sur l'écologie
qu'avons nous à dire sur la défense des
plus fragiles
qu'avons nous à dire sur la société de
surconsommation folle que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui qu'avons nous à
dire sur la lutte contre les violences
conjugales tous ces sujets qui sont des
sujets de blessure du quotidien de nos
concitoyens je pense que ceux qui demain
fera à nouveau la noblesse et l'intérêt
de la politique c'est la sincérité c'est
l'authenticité et c'est la capacité à
apporter des solutions aux problèmes du
quotidien qu'on a souvent négligée moi
je ne veux pas demain faire de la méta
politique je veux pas
me demander si nos sociétés plutôt
libérale étatiste tout ça c'est
formidable ça m'intéresse beaucoup mais
ce qui intéresse les français c'est
comment on règle leurs problèmes au
quotidien et à partir de la liste des
problèmes je ne vous avais pas parlé de
sécurité d'immigration des questions
identitaires est ce que pour vous il
faut que les républicains tourner cette
page aille vers une ligne plus centriste
et non vers une ligne qui était très à
droite qu'est la ligne plutôt d'eric
ciotti de laurent wauquiez est pas une
minute centriste une ligne populaire est
ce que c'est une ligne j'en sais rien
mais en tous les cas redevenir cette
grande famille politique qui parle à
l'ouvrier à la personne modeste la
personne fragile comme à ceux qui qui
qui ont réussi dans notre pays être à
nouveau cette famille politique qui
parle à la jeunesse donc c'est pas une
question de ligne moi je suis certaine
qu on a quand même eric ciotti vont ce
ne sont pas ces sujets prioritaires ces
pays considèrent siva nationale doit
être une droite assumé c'est un bosseur
sa caisse je considère je considère
aussi que la droite doit être de droite
assumé et sur des questions régaliennes
sur les questions de laïcité je n'ai pas
un millimètre d'écart avec mes amis je
dis simplement que désormais ne nous
faut pas abandonner cette jambe la halle
est absolument essentiel mais les
français nous ont beaucoup entendu sur
ces sujets et nous non pas trop ils nous
ont beaucoup entendu et il nous savent
crédible sur ces sujets ont encore eu
lieu il faut de l'aller en fait vous
appelez à une rotation totale ont
terminé reliés à la globe il faut aller
sur tous les autres sujets sur lesquels
on ne nous entend plus et sur lesquels
nous avons des choses à dire oui c'est
une refondation du sol au plafond mais
si nous ne le faisons pas je le redis là
le seul appel à la lucidité que je fais
à mes amis avec qui je discute beaucoup
depuis 72 heures beaucoup plus que
depuis cinq ans parce que j'ai fait des
efforts aient eux aussi et ça nous fait
du bien je leur dis si nous pensons
collectivement qu'on va s'en sortir
comme ça c'est qu'on n'a rien compris au
film est donc oui il faudra que chacun
apporte sa pierre à l'édifice vous voyez
bien une autre vie politique est en
train de de prendre une respiration
profonde dont on ne sait pas où est ce
qu'elle va nous amener les républicains
ne peuvent pas être les seuls à ne pas
le faire mais je vais vous dire
j'ai bon espoir depuis quelques jours
que ce que je dis là soit entendu mais
est-ce que l'édifice il doit continuer à
avoir le même périmètre est-ce que
l'édifice il peut continuer à aller
prévient bertrand de vous jusqu'à
laurent wauquiez eric ciotti est ce qu'à
un moment il faut pas clarifier les
choses et affirmer une ligne plus clair
pour les électeurs mais nous aurons à
trancher cela entre nous en discutons
avec nos militants avec avec les
français et puis et puis avec nous mêmes
moi je pense que notre force immense
c'est cette complémentarité je pense
aussi qu'il faut désormais des portes et
les regards sur tous les sujets que nous
n'avons plus explorées
tout le temps nécessaire pour que les
français nous regardent à nouveau
s'intéresse à nous voient nous
est ce que nous sommes capables de le
faire ensemble je l'espère du fond de
mon coeur de toutes mes forces et ce
durant tout ce qu'il faut je fais tout
ce qu'il faut pour que nous y parvenions
et sinon rien pradier est ce que nos
chemins se séparent et je n'imagine pas
vous dis les choses très simplement et
c'est ma réflexion depuis plusieurs
jours et plusieurs semaines je n'imagine
pas que que que les chemins des uns et
des autres se sépare parce mais si ça va
laisser en l'état de retomber dans des
batailles d'ego aurélien pradié c1 c'est
ça le risque nous n'avons pas le droit
de retomber dans des batailles d'ego
donc il nous faut trouver nos solutions
dans les jours et les semaines qui
viennent pour se dire est ce que nous
avons envie de cette bataille collective
chacun faire un effort et s'entendre sur
la stratégie le succès serveurs
étrangers populaire doit être le
candidat à la présidentielle ou est-ce
que ça va se faire en deux temps non
c'est moi je trouve curieux c'est espèce
de réflexe que nous avons non mais on a
beaucoup entendu
elle avait été désignée trop tort que
duke ouallam à une tante s'installe elle
n'a pas il me sens un projet sans cela
il faut un quelqu'un qui incarne
beaucoup plus tôt ce sont deux choses
différentes que vous évoquez est-ce
qu'il faut préparer beaucoup plus tôt
notre candidat la présidentielle la
réponse est oui est-ce qu'il faut qu'il
soit président du parti je n'en sais
rien j'observe juste que marine le pen
comme jean luc mélenchon comme emmanuel
macron se sont départis de leur parti
politique pour aller devant les français
ce serait curieux que nous fassions un
chemin reliant verdier pour être très
très clair si vous n'étiez pas entendu
dans ce besoin de re fondation et que
finalement la droite républicaine restée
dans ses vieux réflexes vous dit ce sera
sans moi non c'est parce que je vous ai
dit vous comprenez quand même que cette
famille politique c'est l'essentiel de
ma vie politique vous me connaissez un
peu pour savoir que la fidélité la
loyauté c'est quelque chose qui pour moi
est fondamentale et donc je ne veux pas
avoir cette idée là dans la tête je suis
certain que nous avons les ressorts pour
faire respirer notre famille politique
je sais quand je parle de génération ça
hurle parce que me dit mais c'est la
guerre des jeunes contre lise les plus
âgés c'est pas le sujet je dis
simplement que dans des cycles
politiques nous avons aussi besoin d'une
nouvelle génération
quelle n'est pas un problème et qu'elle
peut être un atout pour tout le monde
merci aurélien pradié merci beaucoup
d'avoir été avec nous regarde la une de
la voix du nord emmanuel macron ne lâche
rien c'est à la une de votre journal
merci beaucoup
[Musique]